you're listening to the Rich Eisen show
what's happening is definitely fun to
see her former Carolina Panther and now
free agent looking for a new tee
I'm here on cameo and excited to be a
part of the family I'm here to give you
guys shout outs birthday shout outs
talk to your friends people you like
people you don't like whatever you want
me to do just go ahead and book beyond
cameo comm I'm excited to see what you
guys want me to say all right Devin
Funchess using gonna be a free agent now
he's here on the Rich Eisen show good to
see you Devon
nice seeing you so people could hire you
to say something to people you don't
like no I got accepted I got accept it
is all on me okay so on you so if I have
let's just say Brockman oh okay
all right I think he's you know from New
England
he's a total Masshole would you if I say
I wouldn't accept ok would not accept
that and accept that all right Mike
that's you for when do you turn 53 15
days in 15 days okay so can we we could
do that I could tell them happy birthday
I mean did we just get the milk for free
right there in a way I mean I don't want
to make it so much okay so just give
folks an idea of what they would get on
cameo okay Mike tell two phones right
over there but you can land your camera
right over there he'll see could still
hear you if you want okay cool he turns
how old are you Mike 53 53 years old he
is as he calls himself the Bill Walsh of
audio of the Rich Eisen show okay so
what else can we what else can we
download into Devon to put into his he's
a DJ DJ rollerskating
uh-huh is that you and me to say all
that no just no just you could use
whatever you want okay here we go Devin
Funchess haven't you let me do it right
now sure go ahead
hey how you doing it's Devin Funchess I
want to tell you happy 53rd birthday I
heard you have a special talent on on
the DJ on the DJ all right all right do
a little stuff like that Mike told ya
Mike happy birthday and have a great day
Wow figure yeah actually you can bill us
we could we'll get her some sort of
don't worry about that Mike that his own
birthday wrong his birthday's in 13 yeah
you say 15 days and I can't do man come
on guys no terrible man Wow
so your life's gonna be interesting over
the next week a little bit so what's
going on what can you tell me have you
already heard any sense any rumblings I
don't know anything I mean I was on
Twitter and all that type of stuff and a
different type of fans and groups they
just come attack me and say come here
but you can look at me now you just have
a conversation be cool now now it's just
two michigan guys chopping it all now is
it Sally because I'm chill and I'm
comfortable and good so you have no idea
where I have no idea to Sunday Times I'm
just chilling okay I told I told my
agent disease hit me on Sunday - okay
see what's going on would you have a
sense of who might be interested in you
I think somebody likes me they said they
had they said they said you got
everything you need so hmm yeah I'll do
is continue to be me when did you watch
the receivers in the combine this year I
watched a little bit just because my
little brother he was here we were
working out okay I left I watched a
little bit I saw a couple of guys what
do you think of that kid Metcalf yeah I
saw him run so I was really waiting on
him cuz everybody's talking about I I'm
just more amazing and that he's blessed
coming back from our neck injury right
you saw did you see him facetiming with
his family yeah that's that's what it's
really about not about what he did that
day is is that he came back from that
injury she did it he was there but he's
rocked up oh yeah his human Batman suit
is what Daniel Jeremy yesterday would
say now do you consider him competition
common everybody's competition even my
little brother he's competition as well
so I just got to make sure I continue to
work as continue to grind and make sure
I'm on my peas and Q which is
competition for a spot somewhere right I
mean like you'd rather go to a spa Devin
Funchess can do
some kid coming I don't mess is what I'm
saying my whole thing is I try to
outperform anybody that I've lit but
also at the end of the day we gotta go
get a championship so you're gonna get
to it and I'm getting mine but I still
had to show my abilities as well okay
and what do you what do you bring to the
team versatility I could play anywhere
on the field
the PlayBook is easy to meet whatever
PlayBook you want and then you can teach
size or speech so I'm 64 230 and not
gonna run so whatever you want to do
with that we can do that what's your 40
time right now if you had a roomful if I
had to I probably run about four four
four four two probably that I've been
Funchess I wouldn't lie to you I swear
to God four four two I swear to god what
you want to come back at the combine
that was a different story
come out a different story and did you
go look at the pro day I might was still
dealing with some things right I mean I
got injuries but everybody's injured
while so remember your combine we were
all wondering if you were tied under or
wide receiver tuned because I mean you
played yeah I was doing trying to figure
it out too I started playing football
late I was a basketball star so when I
switch there was this put me on the
field and I would make a play who made
that switch for you I did okay why
because I started losing in love for the
game of basketball so I had to figure
out something else to to make it give me
your game in basketball was the Devin
Funchess hoops camp I see how I want to
get into that because a lot of people
won't try to believe me but it is actual
facts go for you six for what you have
you have a mid-range jumper generator I
got everything I have everything I see I
got the vision I have everything on the
court I have who's your guy would you
emulate your game after we related after
LeBron that was me okay I was a mini I
was a knockoff LeBron cuz he six eight
he's six eight oh six four but I'm
getting off the ground I'm seeing
everybody I I had a good couple averages
so did you just knock on what high
school do you go to father's a nice okay
so you just knocked on the football
coach door and said hey guess what I
want to start playing for we actually
had one of my teammates is Aaron Burr
Burt he was making me kinda jealous
everybody kept talking about him
let me just go ahead and play football
man we got to have him fun we win we
went to the state championship we only
lost one game in high school so it was
like it was we should have had two rings
but we we only had one so that I got
I'll get you on the radar screen of the
Wolverines Brady Hoke yeah not on your
door so that's then that's what happened
huh
we miss again and everybody else and
then after that I mean I did it in two
years with all my scholarships good
football and and then after that I'm I
made it to the league you did make it to
the league and Cam Newton's your
quarterback hmm what type of quarterback
is me cam as you see cam cam it's
exciting he's gonna show you he's gonna
show you things you do not usually see
out of quarterbacks and then he's best
dressed every week so you gotta not
every week every day he's best dressed
every day I've never seen it like it but
I like his sweat how hurt was he last
year he was at cam as a secretive person
so we never know he's just no come game
day we read we got a soldier out there
so that's all we could we could wear is
that so I mean you guys came out first
half of the season looked like in your
step for step with the Saints step for
step with the New Orleans Saints we all
know went to the NFC Championship game
and Saints fans think they should have
gone further mm-hmm but as to does most
of America potentially but you did not
if we could all see a difference you're
sitting at home right I mean did you see
a difference to me I don't I don't
really look at it like that I was just
trying I had we had Curtis and we had a
DJ so I was just trying to make sure my
room was good and and everything was
going good
we the quarterback I never played
quarterback like I came from the
basketball court so all I know is to
take care of yourself and you'll be good
so you're just saying this so you're not
treated like Kelvin Benjamin no no I
feel next time you see him I would never
we have no problem with anybody
damn is really secretive you can ask
anybody no kidding he wouldn't he
doesn't mention it he doesn't say
anything he's no nothing no sir you guys
just told the world with a istagram
he's not like that cam isn't isn't a
type of person for people just be in his
business okay Devin Funchess here on the
Rich Eisen show so let me ask you a
couple questions here about topics of
the day
and Cuyler Murray five foot ten and a
quarter or if it's what five foot ten
and an eighth right I gave him an extra
age right there your do you think a kid
that size can succeed in the NFL yeah I
mean you got Drew Brees I thought it to
be a little bit taller than that there
is Russell Wilson Russell height will
you see he's doing yeah he's a little
bit he's a little bit sturdier one would
think you don't matter don't matter what
about being thrown to by somebody
obviously you don't know something
you've been thrown to by somebody
literally your size it's just the
difference you got to get get it get in
the lab with her just to see the release
anger and all that type of stuff
put some dummies out there for him to
throw over like two six seven I'm and
stuff like that and then after that it
shouldn't be a problem I think here I
come into the NFL not a problem at all
you know I think he exceptional athlete
he won the Heisman so I think he's gonna
be ready for the league okay and your
fellow cameo friend mr. big chest you
know a big test Antonio Brown yeah mr.
big chest okay because that's what he
calls himself Frank I don't keep himself
that he called him Anna yeah exactly do
you think that he can fit in absolutely
anywhere based on what we all learned
week 17 last year he doesn't did he
didn't wasn't with the team and anything
like that do that works into me I've
worked out on Antonio multiple times
that's what I was training and uh an
offseason down in Florida
any team that he goes to they're gonna
be they're gonna they're getting a
blessing the the amount of work that he
puts in amount of effort they I mean the
amount of love that he has for the game
nothing he's gonna be good on any team I
think I don't know what was going on
that's his business but when he gets
that opportunity to step on the field
again I think it's gonna be a special
moment I mean I've met him on occasion
in person I'd love to notice I never
worked out with him you know I'm mister
sizzle chest pretty much right now so
what what type of guy is he
what can you tell fans about who I'm the
same thing that you see on the field he
he has a drive that I can't be matched
as he thinks he can't be matched I try
to I try to go strive his charting both
blow with him so he he's he's
he's a he's a hard-working it doesn't
matter what time I day it is he gonna go
get a workout so that's it with his love
for the game all this stuff off the
field doesn't matter what do you got for
them me over there
oh yeah I talk about his basketball
abilities we found this video from 2015
of Devon that thrown it down Duncan
Duncan jamming it down yeah and a half
court setting no I was on the court I
was I was still hurting a little bit too
so that's not how I really go that's the
old LeBron you know when he goes to the
lane and then here you are this is just
going up his whole head in an alley-oop
situation oh my gosh your head almost
hit the rim there not get higher I was
hurt right there so I can get high
that's what I was trying to tell you at
the combine it was all a fluke I was
time to get her healthy still I'm
exceptional athlete on the basketball
court that's why that's my first love I
love that game so when was the last time
you got out of it it's been a long time
why didn't it just cuz I'm gonna felt
like oh boy my age don't want me to play
he think I'm gonna get hurt cuz I got a
Wednesday pick up week I can't do it I
wish I could Tom would be mad at me he
figured it'd be mad did you see Pat
mahomes out on the floor with the ice
he'll and all that stuff
I see our list so when I think of when
you see that it's cool all right
oh that's cool but me I really was a
Hooper so is this like men oh that's
cool I see everybody everybody I was
coming out with all those videos it's
all good and pistons your team going up
no no it was LeBron mm-hmm you know he's
from Ohio right that's cool how bad how
bad was it late November with Terry
Samuel wasn't it's always bad I'm I told
him everybody new though even tear again
he knew he was still on a team when they
got the first down and all that type of
stuff
oh that's a whole different story so
sperm that they started from that moment
he started from that moment the first
down it was not a first down it's not
even take in knows it wasn't first down
now hold on a second he knows that even
today I have his head get on the show he
will tell me that he will tell you that
he will tell me they would tell you that
and if he doesn't he just called me well
you know who the one who set it up on
fourth and short was Curtis yeah I know
do not and then Curtis got it set up
fourth and and no question JT Barrett
was short he was sure everybody knows
it's just Curtis know he knows it well
Curtis admit that he was he will never
admit it you know I will stay people off
I'm telling just call me just call me
when do you have Ted Gaines number yes
can we call him right now
you want to call him right now yeah
let's take a break in common will you
call Ted Ginn right we'll call him can
we take a call okay we could take a
break and we're calling Ted Ginn to do
it and here's okay here's the deal if
you come back here for the commercial
break we'll have reached Ted Ginn but we
can't you know I don't want to hold you
if we reach his voicemail we'll see what
it is I don't think yeah I think he
might answer well not if he's watching
this he's gonna duck is TVs is like be
hit oh he does not okay god what we call
good stuff in the meantime sir good luck
to you priest okay
at D underscore punch on Twitter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience